okay I've told you about the revolting
repulsive sickening stomach-churning
foul and nasty hypocrisy Louis of
Republican politicians voting against
federal aid for natural disasters
outside of their district and then
asking for federal aid when something
happens inside of their district and one
example from a year or so ago it was
Oklahoma Republicans who voted against
federal aid for hurricane sandy victims
in New York and New Jersey and then
asked for aid for tornado victims in
their home state of Oklahoma there are
many examples and I have one related to
the flooding in Louisiana which is that
three Republicans in Louisiana who voted
against supplemental aid for hurricane
sandy now we're demanding that the
government give them flood relief money
I am talking about none other than Steve
Scalise Bill Cassidy and John Fleming
fiscal responsibility and a tight
checkbook and small government very very
important until it's your own district
that's in trouble and then the
government needs to do the right thing
to help people in their time of need
blah blah blah which by the way I agree
with I just agree with it when it's not
just your own district that means help
and they asked President Obama for a
disaster declaration in a letter a few
days ago of course President Obama
signed it he declared it a disaster area
Flemming Scalise and Cassidy by the way
are also climate change deniers which I
mean there's we could do an hour just on
these three individuals
I actually don't support keeping aid
away from the people of Louisiana right
they deserve the aid the problem is that
the politicians should be punished for
their utter hypocrisy and I get it you
need to represent your district but you
also need to be morally consistent now
they've been asked for comment on this
they do have an explanation as to why
they don't think they are being
hypocritical here and the explanation is
and this came from Steve Scalise is
spokesperson the money that they asked
for under the disaster declaration was
already appropriated by FEMA the money
is already there it's just a matter of
declaring Louisa
flooding a disaster area so that they
can get the money the hurricane sandy
money was supplemental money above and
beyond what had already been allocated
this is one of the stupidest
explanations I've ever heard because in
both cases you're talking about money
that is at some point appropriated by a
legislative decision yes the FEMA money
was previously appropriated hurricane
sandy required additional money it's all
money that our elected officials vote on
this explanation is so boneheaded that
it's almost embarrassing that they're
even saying this and they shouldn't have
to because the the extent of the damage
that caused by Hurricane sandy yeah
of course was greater than than what the
allocated money would cover of course
and so it is hypocrisy and also I you
know I don't know these guys personally
know I'm sure that they're the best
people absolutely but I do know people
like them and I bet you that there's a
chance that they are only asking for
this money so that they can get
reelected and do they really care about
their constituents I would like to think
that they do and I don't think thank you
you genuinely think they don't care at
all about the individuals that vote for
them as people I mean how many stories
have recovered over the years that made
it very clear that politicians like this
don't actually care about the
constituents and just want to be in
these positions and have their eyes set
on on higher office as well
are you as cynical Jason about all
elected officials as is Lewis yeah
that's why I'm still you know I've been
debating this I'm still in the no vote
camp I'm staying home I think still in
November oh yeah okay we'll talk about
that we'll have a conversation about
that a little bit later please by the
way start sending in the messages about
why what Jason is saying is outrageous
and he should vote in November and I'll
start compiling them and we'll we'll
have plenty of time to deal with that
right I mean there's pressing matters
now going on including what's happening
in Louisiana Gamefly is sort of like
Netflix for video games they have over
8,000 new and classic games for xbox one
Xbox 360 ps4 PS
we and a bunch of other platforms and
you can play as many games as you want
for one monthly fee and if you find some
games you want to keep you can buy them
for a low used price there's never any
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a free 30-day trial at Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s